Dallas cross the blue line it's Jamie Ben holds up
looks across the sheet t gorv d donov for Johnston
in front Ben denied Point Blank and then gorgia
without the stick fought off a second effort
with the blocker ranted it slipped forward for
McKinnon he's got some space feeds it across to
Mar dangerous guys on the ice for the ABS nushin
shot the save made by AER with the right arm held
in Marchman near the point he shot read Direction
and haena The defenseman cutting from the corner
through the slot and just stayed wide Marchman
he'll flip it in front caught nicely shot score
what a Play Tyler Sean out of midair had the
angle that line picks up where they left off
on Tuesday and open the scoring well they were on
the hunt and aggressive it started with yni hawen
being aggressive as a defenseman adding a fourth
guy all of a sudden the confusion of the Avalanche
what a terrific Trap by Sean on the feet in front
Marchman little saier himself and then a fade away
Dagger from Tyler San over the short side shoulder
it's a big goal for Tyler too that moves him up
the list a little bit you know you forget OK
Conor left side shot that off the bar hinan has
six assists on the power play and back underneath
the Stick of Ben Ben in the trapezoid behind the
net fed it in front gorg EV got a piece but not
all of it and the Stars score pelski [Applause]
quick work again on the power play Dallas has
doubl there their lead yeah they're starting
to trot and they're going to work on the
Avalanche from in behind the icing line
they've done this a couple of times they they
did it at even strength this time they work
it on the power play able to just slide
a PO Ben was set up like grety he out in
front all the Avalanche penalty killers are
staring at Jamie Ben nobody gets under the
stick Eric furat working the game with
Jordan Samuels Thomas Bon Mills Julian
fornier have the Lions shot Marksman and he
rung it off the post from the left wing side
three pretty good looks at at ainger in the
game Stars take over asind Del he shot save
rebound score Tyler San he's got number two on
the night and the stars have a three nothing
lead that spot away and then the stars on the
hunt on their for check Gerard turns the puck
over and then he gets slid by by Tyler s he gets
just caught watching in front Stars turned that
bobbl loose Puck into a shot on go a real
intelligent nice work by the Stars Captain
so Dallas can set back up in the attack Zone
rope hints Ben in front pavelski denied from
close range guar collects along the wall
takes a few steps in Retreat that turns
it over a shot gorgi at the Save and oh
it was right to Sean stars with a five on
three bring across the Blue Line 18 seconds
left on it Wyatt Johnston duaine centers
hins and saved by gorv Bend from that left
Circle but it's Colorado who wins that one
they don't clear however and the stars go to
work hints across now Ben Point Blank tapped
gorev Jones off of Olson Stars race back
in marchment with a couple helpers in the
game feeds it Gori have the save great look for
Craig Smith that's your first job do not do what
he just did this time he banked it ahead Colton
Springs in wood has half a step and scores that
puck slid underneath AER there was a delayed
call coming up and wood takes the goal instead
Colorado gets on the board heavy physical depth
forward but he's got great Wheels he showed it
there they were able to slip in behind the Stars
defense just a relay in neutral ice Nils lanquist
couldn't catch up to him gave him a stab tinger
and Retreat he got bumped into as that puck was
basically jammed in and it was the skates and
the Collision this would be the first challenge
the stars have this season and yeah it looks for
sure like they are going to Dallas is challenging
the goal for goaler interference first is the
head video coach Dallas coach has challenge
there was no goer interference it was a good
go Dallas has theame Colorado has been able to
generate much so far on this power play down to
the closing seconds they turn it over for Fox a
short-handed save gorgi have got enough Ronin
and Johansson lead Colorado with three a piece
send it low ranted in and reading it well auder
had that left hand ready and snared it with the
glove then the faceoff man for Dallas jumped a few
times Johansson Colorado's best Faceoff man wins
it no Lane Ranon in then a one-timer scored M let
a rip and a power play goal for the ABS makes it
a one-goal game face offs right the stars have
been winning all theirs on the power play bib
man and Johansson pulls this away from Jamie
b and a ripper with all that Criss Crossing
body it looked like it changed directions on its
way in yeah it did in the slot and it'll be the
center ieman that ended up winning that draw
that think is going to get credited with the
goal it's a different combo but still three
former Stars forwards shot sizzling change
direction to win up high now to chushin
high slot to the left side back in front
nushin scores the Stars intercepted the pass
but then handed it over to nushin ties the
game well this feel felt like it was going
to happen at some point tonight because B's
been dangerous almost every time he's been on
the ice big power forward you know the sweep
check at the net by Marchman I believe it was
who was trying to handle things down there as
the forward does the right thing he had Olson
right on his back but laid it right into the
Wheelhouse of Tyler San's old linemate and not
much chance on a bit of a shocker for tinger out
of the reach mostly of Ben who did well to poke
it and start this Counterattack Johnston behind
the net to donov wrap around save made
right pad goria nushin pays him back for
nushin somehow stayed in with
possession and a backhand score
by Colorado it was ranin who got the
puck and roofed it up high the first
time tonight the Stars Trail the fourth
straight goal in the game for Colorado
Johnston over for duchaine back for w Johnston
off the body ggia Puck loose fought off stayed
out opposite Colton the stars do control
it hykin and up near the line hands it
off to the right duchaine for Sean broken up
before he could shoot it into the empty net
the dagger delivered Ross Colton from 2/3
of the ice and it'll go down as the sixth
straight Colorado goal and put this one away
and instead of just one pass find a lane and
get it into the humanity in front they try
for the slot pass and the Avalanche blocks
it through Center Ice cross the line stood
up that'll be the final play of the game
as the horn sounds the Avalanche pull off
a reversal go from three down to three up